oh hi guys it is Friday or on its grace
and normally this would be the day I do
Friday Marie's however I got my travel
camera back from Hannah Hart and I did
not charge the batteries uh move on Stan
I decided that today I'm going to answer
some of your questions I went on my
tumblr and asked you guys for questions
and I'm going to answer them sincerely
and honestly and inspirationally
remember when you're a younger and he
thought smiling was just showing your
teeth well my little brother used to
think that smiling was just showing his
teeth so we have a series of photos from
when he was like 2 to 6 where everyone
is smiling and he's doing this
subscribe to Tim here on YouTube channel
to show you any advice on how to be a
creative slash live a creative life
style sweatpants and chips and then also
try and eat salsa with your chips from
time to time because then you can feel
like I had vegetables today favorite
facial expression that one how the beep
are you so damn funny did you just fall
asleep in your car and your head hit the
horn are you ok are you ok
beep twice if you're OK what's your fave
pizza topping nachos hi I'm grace Helbig
and when I'm sad I drown my sorrows in
exploring my thoughts and feelings to a
group of strangers on the Internet
okay-y no fry diary look I got the
camera back that's step one step two is
taking the time to charge the battery
you can't rush these things I'm not a
[ __ ] okay agriculture what do you call a
really temperamental yogurt agriculture
what the did you just see a fish walking
on land and you had to express yourself
via the comments section on my tumblr
post asking for your questions if so
beep twice how to stay positive during
exams you never want to be positive
during exams it is so much more annoying
to take all of your final exams knowing
that you're pregnant last thing you
bought another 48 pack of toilet paper
off of amazon.com girl is doing it right
any advice for moving to a new city find
the nearest liquor store Target and
grocery store nothing else really
matters I guess a hospital but like
Target probably has whatever you would
need my 19th birthday is tomorrow any
funny memories from that age no if you
were going to write a memoir what would
you call it the diary of mamrie Hart
what a fast and furious time this was oh
my god who knew chips chips you're not
supposed to do this were there you go
there are some of my answers to your
questions I hope that you enjoyed them
if you didn't enjoy them
I don't know what else I can do for you
other than just leave and get out of
your life but as clearly you have to be
here but I should go so I don't know can
you put your foot behind your head can
you put a dick in your mouth
oh cool